[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro vous êtes en direct et
on attend vos points de vue notamment
sur cette question qu'on vous pose sur
le site du figaro faut-il instaurer un
couvre-feu dernière idée dans l'air pour
contrer la propagation de l'aco vide
dix neuf on demandera ce soir son point
de vue à vous bien sûr et à brice
couturier bonsoir brice journaliste
chroniqueur chaque jour un france
culture 11h53 le tour du monde des idées
et on confrontera vos points de vue vos
points de vue avec ceux de alexis brézet
bonsoir alexis directeur des rédactions
du groupe figaro le figaro qui a publié
en avant première un grand entretien du
général pierre de villiers a retrouvé
tout de suite d'ailleurs dans le tchad
ont voulu mais l'ancien cema publie un
nouveau livre doit-il à jouer un rôle
pour ou en 2022
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur
twitter etc le débat l'autre débat qu'on
vous propose ce soir mais d'abord
faut-il instaurer un couvre feu c'est la
question qu'on vous pose sur le site du
figaro vous êtes pour l'instant une
majorité à répondre oui on va bientôt
voir les premiers résultats vous êtes
très nombreux également à voter
sera-t-il instauré on va c'est la
question en tout cas qui était posée ce
matin à marlène schiappa à lci je vous
propose d'écouter un couvre-feu en ile
de france est envisageable
je crois que tout est envisageable très
honnêtement tout est sur la table et
rien n'est à exclure
il ya d'autres mesures qui sont sur la
table et qui sont envisagées
très localement un couvre-feu maintenant
brice vous partager l'avis de la
majorité qui s'expriment actuellement
sur le site du figaro il ya un conseil
de défense qui a eu lieu ce matin à
l'elysée
sur ce sujet il ya une réunion des
ministres concernés qu aura lieu ce soir
à matignon et demain le présent d'un
public à 19h45 vous dira quelles sont
ses conclusions moi ce que j'observe
surtout c'est que pour l'instant le
couvre-feu il existe déjà dans plusieurs
villes notamment en allemagne à berlin
et à francfort
il existe à londres à 22h depuis déjà un
certain nombre de semaines et il a
failli exister à madrid où pourtant le
pro de la plus haute instance judiciaire
de madrid a décidé que ça ne
s'appliquerait pas parce que les
autorités madrilènes étaient ils étaient
hostiles alors que c'était une décision
du premier ministre espagnol pour qu'on
voit bien que dans le madrid qui à
droite et le gouvernement espagnol que
baisse était un sujet qui va se reposer
chez nous de manière probable aussi
puisqu'on voit bien que si le président
n'a public annonce ce type de
confinement on voit bien que la maire de
paris y est il est relativement épargnée
pas favorables parce que évidemment un
centre d'activités économiques risquent
d'en pâtir terriblement notamment la
restauration et les activités nocturnes
parce que j'observe c'est en lisant on
the guardian anglais c'est que
finalement ce couvre feu instauré à 22h
à londres ne fonctionne pas très bien en
réalité parce que les jeunes font la
fête devant les bars qui boivent
énormément convoi énormément de
d'étudiants en dans un dans un état
alcoolique à ses avances et bien après
les 22 heures qui sont l'heure de la
fermeture des pubs et des bars si je
comprends bien s'il y avait un coup de
feu de forêt revenir oui si on répare et
ouverture débarque chez nous donc les
jeunes ne pouvaient pas faire la fête
devant les verts puisque ce sont les
bars et son terme et je vous rappelle
celui je suis pas du tout sûr qu'ils
couvrent moi ce que je remarque c'est
que avant chaque grande intervention
présidentielle on ne l'est on est parti
dans les prophéties les plus et les
annonces les plus terribles
on va interdire ceux ci attendaient cela
toutes les options sont sur la table
c'est ce que oui mais ça passe à ça cela
langage visuel mais le le bruit
médiatique qui courent les rumeurs les
gens qui m'appellent tu sais que il
paraît que il paraît comme d'interdire
il paraît que l'armée appelée voulu au
moment du grand confinement il paraît
que l'armée va nous imposer nous
interdire de quitter paris il paraît
qu'on va faire ceci près qu'on va faire
cela à chaque fois ce n'était pas le cas
à chaque fois ça n'est jamais le
président mabri qui annonce et les
les mauvaises nouvelles donc je suis pas
du tout sûr qu'il le fasse pour vous
dire le fond de ma pensée je suis pas
sûr de l'absolue nécessité aujourd'hui
de faire un couvre feu
alors après c'est vrai que c'est très
compliqué parce qu'on voit quand même
bien que qu' il ya quelque chose qu'un
train de repartir c'est évident on voit
aussi quand même que l'ampleur de cette
ce qu'il faut appeler sa vague
vaguelettes début de vague n'a rien à
voir ex que c'était aux grands moments
de dudu cours du mois de mars dernier
on sent que ce qu'on appelle le taux
d'incidence et le nombre de tests
mesurée est en progression faramineuse
mais oui mais il ya beaucoup plus de
tests et en plus maintenant on ne le
fait plus que sur les gens symptomatique
donc si on laisse beaucoup de gens qui
sont tous symptomatique est quand même
pas mal de choses qu'on ait beaucoup de
cas ce qui au mois de mars y en ait
beaucoup moins il ya six mois il y avait
beaucoup moins de tests et donc y avait
beaucoup moins de cas constatés donc ça
on peut pas vraiment comparer ce qu'on
peut comparer ces les entrées à
l'hôpital qui sont en progression mais
pour l'instant qui reste encore des pas
dans les proportions de l'armée rien à
voir rien à voir et je ne parle pas des
décès qui reste quand même la pierre de
touche de toute politique de santé
publique pourquoi est-ce qu'on envisage
de bloquer un pays
pourquoi est-ce qu'on envisage de
prendre des mesures regret la victime
était un peu une pipe ou de cristiano
liberté qui met à bas notre économie qui
minent le moral des gens qui accable la
jeunesse pour qu'on peut le pourquoi on
peut envisager de le faire c'est parce
qu'il faut éviter des morts
éventuellement pour l'instant cet
indicateur là et reste 10 à 12 fois
moins fort que comme un art alors après
la série dexter vous diront oui mais
c'est avant qu'il faut arrêter les
choses pour ne pas que ça monte et que
ça arrive peut-être pour ça que je pense
que moi je suis réservé en tout cas je
ne suis pas du tout sûr que le président
s'oriente vers ça il peut aussi continue
faire de la pédagogie dire comme il l'a
fait plusieurs fois on nous allons
encore continuer nous allons durcir un
petit peu tel point ou tel point
mais avant de prendre des mesures plus
dures nous allons nous laisser quelques
jours et puis c'est souvent qu'elle
souvent le seul scénario c'est le
président laisse entendre que peut-être
on va faire quelque chose et trois jours
après on le fait c'est la faute
c'est cet internaute qui disent la faute
aux médias qui disent n'importe quoi
la faute aux médias que des moeurs
classe la faute aux médecins qui disent
n'importe quoi c'est la photo aux
français qui dit
n'importe quoi c'est surtout la faute au
virus parce que la vérité c'est qu'on ne
sait pas trop ce qu'il faut dire ce
qu'il faut faire et qu'il ya aucun pays
ou en tout cas en europe et même au
monde qui a trouvé l'absolu réponse on
sent bien que ça repart un peu partout
donc on est il ya aussi d'une certaine
impuissance ignorance qu'il faut avouer
face à quelque chose qui nous dépasse
bref je redonne la parole je salue les
internautes je salue d'avoir christian
léon qui nous dit c'est son anniversaire
bonne anniversaire qui se tient à lyon
et claude le dis je ne vois pas
l'utilité d'un couvre-feu si riche il ya
il se transmet aussi bien le jour voire
plus que la nuit à mon sens le
couvre-feu servira surtout pour éviter
la délinquance plus que pour stopper
l'épidémie
quelle sera la peine encourue si on ne
respecte pas le couvre-feu fait nous
demande philippe ça encore faut-il qu'il
y ait un couvre feu qui soit instaurée
brice jeu on a vu les forains hier dans
la rue les maîtres d'hôtel et les
hôtesses aujourd'hui nicolas baverez
il voit une rébellion de la société qui
sait ce qui s'explique par jeu de cycle
mélange explosif d'autoritarisme de
centralisme et d'impuissance de l'état
oui j'ai trouvé cet éditorial de baverey
extraordinaire excellent comme tous ses
éditoriaux du reste oui il a raison
bien entendu il ya une exaspération de
la société face à ce qu'elle perçoit
comme une incohérence de la part des
pouvoirs publics
en réalité il faut quand même voir que
face à une situation qui est
particulièrement inédite les pouvoirs
publics navigue à vue parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le choix ils s'adaptent à la
situation enfants furent et à mesure
qu'elle évolue donc qu'on peut pas non
plus jeter la pierre il ya aucun pays je
pense qu'il ya aucun pays aucun
gouvernement mons dans le monde face à
cette épidémie qui a eu la juste réponse
sauf peut-être singapour et la corée du
sud
parce que eux ils ont vraiment mis en
oeuvre ce qu'il fallait probablement
faire depuis le début parce qu'ils ont
une société aussi qu'il adapte le
traçage l'isolément le
le tester systématiquement la population
tracer tous les cas est isolé tous les
malades
ça demande une société qui est un très
fort sentiment de cohésion qui respecte
les autorités et qui s'adapte nous c'est
dépassé pas notre cas c'est aussi un
domaine qui m'intéresse beaucoup j'ai
l'impression que on est face à des
sociétés qui réagissent de manière
extrêmement différentes
nous on est on est des sociétés qui ont
très peu de sens civique qui ont très
peu de confiance dans les institutions
ou les individus ont très peu de
confiance les uns envers les autres
regardez la suède c'est l'anti modèle
ils ont rien confiné ils ont ils ont pas
fermée ils ont continué leurs activités
parce qu'ils ont une société qui est
beaucoup plus civique que la nôtre oui
ça va pas mieux que chez nous mais ils
ont pris le moins de mesures tous
autoritaire mais plus de mesures auto
administré et je pense que ça explique
grandement la différence grandement la
défense 4 nos cultures et les cultures
asiatiques vont vous dont vous parlez
que cette culture confucéenne qui repose
sur le collectif où finalement les
mécanismes de coercition sont des
mécanismes internes à la société qu'elle
s'appliquait elle même donc ce n'est pas
l'état qui dit c'est au fond c'est la
coercition à l'échelle de l'individu qui
s'auto contre une seconde auto contre
dont on est bien éloignée mais je prends
pressé de préciser que je m'en réjouis
je pense que notre culture de liberté à
me paraît en tout cas beaucoup plus
agréable à vivre
je ne vois pas mais pas du tout saga
pour rien ou coréens mais bon si on
regarde la réaction des opinions
je pense qu'on n'est pas encore stable
de la révolte juste de le dire ce qui
est vrai c'est que l'adhésion est quand
même de plus en plus fragile
le sondage que vous avez craqué pas un
sondage l'enquète auprès des lecteurs du
film sur dur de nos internautes
je sais pas combien ont répondu master
6585 70000 non non on va on va regarder
70000 je vais je vais regarder en direct
sur le site et je vous donne toutes là
ça commence c'est pas un sondage mais ça
c'est intéressant
toutes les premières enquêtes qu'on
faisait au début c'était dans le sens de
la sécurité de toujours plus de sécurité
toujours plus finalement deux de
répression pour des impératifs
sanitaires c'était hors de 90 à 80 %
et puis on est passé à 70 % là on arrive
à 55%
c'est pas tant que ça c'est pas une
adhésion massive ça veut dire que à près
de 80 mille autres voilà 80 mille
votants c'est pas un sondage mais pas de
représentativité
mais quand 80 milles
on sort et surtout on peut le comparer
aux autres je constate depuis le début
que les taux de oui aux mesures de
protection et qui était écrasant restent
majoritaires mais de moins en moins
majoritaire
donc ça s'éteint c'est quand même une
indication sur l'évolution de l'opinion
en général
et qu'est ce qui énerve les gens ce que
je voudrais pas ce que dit brice qui me
paraît très juste je pense qu'un autre
élément c'est le sentiment
comment dire d'injustice et vous
gouvernants vous nous reprochez vous
nous dites que c'est notre faute parce
qu'on se conduit mal vous est peut-être
pas tort mais vous êtes un peu gonflé
parce que vous avez vous aussi vous avez
fait 20 heures et vous pouvez me
faudrait les reconnaître et c'est vrai
que quand on entend mieux castex qui en
gros dit nous on a tout bien fait après
le confinement on a dit on a pris toutes
les mesures et les français ont fait
n'importe quoi pendant l'été sans doute
est vrai n'ont pas pris les précautions
qui devrait prendre d'abord on l'aura
pas d'eux tandis que ça faut pas
exagérer deuxièmement si on n'avait pas
raté les tests les masques avant puis
les tests puis le traçage puis
aujourd'hui la question des lits de
réanimation
peut-être curé - lieu de reprocher aux
français de ne pas prendre les
précautions qu'il faut aussi doivent
prendre toutes ses précautions c'est
parce que tous ces points qu'on vient
d'évoquer son des ratages bureaucratique
et administratif
faut quand même pas l'oublier alors est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un autre phénomène qui
qui entrent en ligne de compte
jean castex reçoit les ministres pour
parler ce soir mais une question qui
vient à l'esprit enfin qu'on peut lire
d'ailleurs dans les faux mais c'est à
quoi joue le gouvernement
je vous propose de réécouter d'avoir ce
que disait hier le premier ministre sur
les prochaines vacances de la toussaint
et c'était donc dans son interview hier
matin à france info
le mot d'ordre c'était pas trop de
rencontres et pas trop de bise à papis
et mamies et papys et mamies ou pas
pendant les vacances alors si on peut
les voir on ne peut les voir je vais pas
vous dire qu'on va voir peut être un ami
en fait ce serait ridicule alors qu'ils
ont fait avec le faire on fait très
attention en fait attention porte le
masque au maximum en tout cas s'agissant
du papy puisque vous savez que pour les
petits enfants même le port du masque en
dessous d'un certain âge et des
commandes et on évite au maximum les
contacts
on est très prudent voilà on est très
prudent si on peut éviter d'ailleurs de
partir en vacances est un peu mieux et
quelques heures plus tard voilà le
message du secrétaire d'état au tourisme
jean baptiste lemoyne et mamie ou pas
pendant les vacances alors si on peut
les voir
je dis aux français organisez vos
déplacements organiser vos vacances
faites le avec confiance parce que les
professionnels et voir ou lampard sont
engagés à une chose c'est que si il doit
y avoir une allure une annulation à un
moment à cause de cette épidémie
eh bien les français seront remboursés
il n'y aura pas de pénalité et surtout
allez voir par votre saillie la question
dans un instant aux pages du général de
villiers dénoncent un manque
d'anticipation un manque de vision de
l'état dans la gestion de la crise du
colis de la dans les échanges des
extraits convient de voir c'est ce qu'on
vient de voir série ado logique qui se
télescopent
c'est une logique sanitaire évidemment
kessel ministère de la santé si on
écoutait admise de la santé oms
resterait à toucher d'autres en six mois
et l'économie s'effondrerait vous avez
une logique par ailleurs économique qui
veut que la france est un grand pays
touristique et qu'il faut que le
tourisme continue
vous avez une logique économique qui
veut aussi que les entreprises
continuent à travailler qu'ils resteront
continuer à travailler
bref que le pays continue à travailler
parce que l'état est au bout de ce qu'il
peut faire en matière de relance de
l'économie de l'activité économique il
le fait on commençait par un endettement
spectaculaire on peut pas continuer
comme ça il faut qu'il faut que le pays
se remette à travailler parce que entre
entre la mort par le cos vide et la mort
par l'asphyxié économique
il va falloir choisir et il ya donc deux
de façon de voir le monde de logique et
de ligne au sein du gouvernement
le sens bien depuis le début on sent
très bien que effectivement verra sur
les faits remontent au bloquons tout
c'est la faute des français que le
conseil de sécurité r2 delfraissy est
sur la même ligne que si on les écoutait
on nous bouclerait à double le conseil
scientifique nous doublerons bouclera
double tour pendant six mois au bas mot
petit moi c'est vraiment celle de la
base après ça c'est encore mieux si peu
et qu'il yad'autres côté emmanuel macron
qui lui n'est pas sur cette ligne là on
le sent très bien
il fait tout ce qu'il peut à chaque fois
pour essayer de retarder encore une
minute monsieur le bourreau et qui fait
tous parce que lui à l'économie c'est
pas que des questions même d'argent
l'économie c'est la santé des gens aussi
c'est la dpc c'est le mal être
psychologique des gens qui sont en train
d'être ruinés désespérée d'une jeunesse
qui est en train de tourner en bourrique
parce qu'ils peuvent plus rien faire ils
peuvent plus être différés enfin qu'ils
peuvent plus sortir le soir
donc ça va au delà des
question d'économie stricto sensu qui
elles mêmes sont extraordinairement
importante notre tissu économique est en
train de s'effondrer
donc c'est normal que vous rendrez
public et puis sophie nan c'est pas son
tempérament c'est vrai qu'il est depuis
le début pour le meilleur et pour le
pire il est il est dans la dynamique
l'optimisme
il n'est pas dans la protection on lui a
suffisamment reproché d'ailleurs donc il
ya deux lignes
depuis rien castex comme edouard
philippe d'ailleurs qui passe de l'une à
l'autre il sait pas très bien selon les
interventions selon les jours on le sent
plus tôt et sergio sont plutôt côté vers
an plus tôt côté macro et avec avec
derrière toujours que s'agissant du
préjudice que ce soit a fini boussois
jean castex quelque chose qu'on peut
déplorer mais qu'on peut comprendre
c'est le souci des conséquences
judiciaires
le premier ministre a toujours en tête
l'idée si je ne garantis pas si je ne me
protège pas si j'ai pas la vie d'un tel
d'intel et d'intel pour me verrouillé
pour verrouiller ma position je risque
de me traîner devant la justice
ce qui n'est pas le cas du président
d'un public faut le rappeler il est
responsable donc ça change les choses on
peut pas il ya aussi le fait que comme
par hasard castex c'était monsieur
déconfinement donkey salut salut reste
alors que edouard philippe était connu
comme quelqu'un d'extrêmement
pragmatique de précautionneux castex lui
il a symbolisé en tout cas c'est ce que
mc on voulait passer comme message c'est
que quelque part l'épidémie était
derrière nous et que la relance était là
or castex il est obligé de gérer une
deuxième vague et on lit donc passé de
monsieur déconfinement monsieur rona
finement il en train de devenir des
volumes n'oublions pas tous ces gens qui
nous ont dit qu'ils auraient pas de
deuxième vague a entre parenthèses ils
sont sacrément trompé il faudrait en
attendant nathan leurs excuses justin
d'un un dernier point pour ça parce que
il ya deux lignes qui s'affrontent mais
au bout d'un moment il va falloir tendre
et renchérit basroch comment dire il ne
pourrait pas il ya deux lignes et c'est
au fond c'est assez logique il ya deux
façon dont ces deux ça c'est comme dans
une tragédie personne n'a tort personne
n'a raison les deux logiques sauver des
vies les économistes ont tous les deux
sont légitimes et donc ce serait absurde
en choisir une fois pour toute et de
dire une fois pour tour a laissé mourir
tout le monde parce que l'économie doit
vivre ou à l inverse on va tous fermés
donc petit à petit on s'adapte et c'est
vrai que ça donne cette impression mais
c'est inévitable
c'est à dire que ça sert à rien de
prendre de l'avancé sur les mesures
coercitives
tant qu'on peut aller que faire que
l'économie garde un peu la tête hors de
l'eau il faut
et après il faut doser faut trouver le
juste équilibre d'aucune
un équilibre alors c'est bien fait mal
fait avec des allers retours c'est la
vie qui est comme ça il ya vraiment deux
façons de voir les choses
le couvre feu est une sorte de
confinement nous dit babineau qui
rejoint brice couturier le gouvernement
envisage des formes de confinement car
une faillite de la stratégie tester
tracé isolé et il estime que c'est
plutôt les lignes sanitaires devaient
rang qui semble avoir pris le pas sur la
ligne de macron dans les commentaires
dans la musique médiatique depuis hier
attendons demain peut-être jeu mais je
pense que je enfin je sais que je n'en
sais rien mais je pense que personne
n'en sait rien et je ne suis même pas
sûr que accroc emmanuel macron message
en quel sens il va pencher son
tempérament c'est de dire gardons une
porte à l'espoir ne fermons pas tous
deux des sports en parler français et
c'est ça c'est ça tempérament sa
prudence est ce qu'on lui dit c'est
attention faut tout refaire mais qu'est
ce qui va faire je ne le sais pas
faut-il instaurer un couvre feu c'est la
question qu'on vous posez sur le site du
figaro vous êtes près de 80000 a déjà
vous être exprimé si vous ne l'avez pas
fait et bah vous pouvez continuer à le
faire donc on est toujours sûr
effectivement ce premier chiffre de 2,54
à 54,93 et maintenant on est à 54 87 en
temps réel voilà vous allez les ouïes
l'autre les quais l'autre question qu'on
vous pose cette fois ci elle est sur
twitter j'ai et sur youtube le général
de villiers pierre de villiers doit-il
jouer un rôle il est de retour sur la
scène médiatique et éditoriales
troisième et nouveau livre l' équilibre
est un cousin et un courage sujet verbe
complément c'est le style qu'affectionne
l'auteur je suis guidé par la passion et
l'amour de la france je vais au travers
de mes entretiens de mes déplacements
une mes activités avec la jeunesse les
associations les entreprises partager
cette voie de la réconciliation voici
voilà pardon ma nouvelle façon de servir
c'est ce qu'il déclare donc à alexandre
ii vecchio et à la question pensez-vous
à 2022 réponse je suis navré de voir que
finalement les élections de 2022 ne sont
vus qu'à l'aune du vide actuel
je suis là pour contribuer au débat et
faire passer les idées face au
délitement actuelle l'urgence est de
réfléchir et de construire des projets
pour la france
alexis en lisant ça j'ai pas vu
quelqu'un qui disait oui mais
contrairement à ce qu'on entend beaucoup
dire je lis pas quelqu'un qui dit non je
me trompe c'est très intéressant
le l'écho le début de deux rumeurs
commencent à courir autour de pierre de
villiers est ce qu'il sera candidat sera
oui dis pas non il dit pas oui mais ce
qui brille et puis la décision on verra
bien celle qui prendra mais je trouve ça
intéressant de voir qu'est ce que ça
veut dire de la société française de se
projeter dans une personne telle que
finalement les gens connaissent pas
beaucoup qu'est ce qu'ils savent de lui
qui s'appelle pierre de vidéos la ville
et les gens connaissent le nom qui était
chef d'état major des armées donc ils
patron des armées qui s'est fait virer
par macron de façon brutale et qu' il
est parti avec dignité
ils se souviennent pour certains de
somme et encore pas tous et ensuite qui
fait un livre dans lequel il parle de
quoi
de fraternité de dignité d'honneur de
droiture toutes ses vertus éminemment
militaire qui parle aux gens et qu'ils
ont sans doute ils ont un hall s'agit
quand il voit aujourd'hui le jeu
politique qui se déroulait à 6 les
hommes politiques pouvaient être franc
du collier droit honnête carré comme
comme une vertu qu'on prête par
définition un officier supérieur
l'officier général parce que ce sont des
vertus finalement celle de l'institution
militaire
on va projeter et qu'on va projeter sur
pierre de vie et qu'il les pratiques sur
mais qu'au fond c'est le sait le fait
d'être d'être ce qu'il est qui va faire
qu'il est le réceptacle de ça et moi
j'ai un peu de mémoire politique je me
souviens d'autres j'aimerais le général
morillon à une époque
est-ce que vous souvenez de généralement
brion jeu dans le mourillon des quatre
en beauce briller bosnie cette hâte
c'est vrai dit shah et qui avait incarné
général courage puisque et donc elle
veut garder une sorte d'espoir politique
il avait été d'ailleurs député européen
de surseoir bayrou françois bayrou et
c'était c'était le général quoi acheter
je me souviens mais use n'ai pas
beaucoup trop jeunes du général jeannou
lacaze grands officiers officiers qui a
fait l'indochine
patron des cerfs des services d'abord du
service action enfin des troupes de choc
spéciale des forces spéciales et je
crois ensuite de deux des renseignements
ou et qui a dû à 38 peut-être chef
d'état-major des armées ou ou de le chef
d'état-major des armées aussi général
jeannou lacaze qui à une époque alors
c'était encore dix ans plus tôt à comme
ça incarner une sorte de recours face à
la la médiocrité à la facilité des
politiciens et d'ailleurs il était élu
lui aussi député européen jusqu'à
présent les jeunes on arrive à se faire
détenir député rover pour le coup je
crois que c'était le cni ou le sénat bon
tout ça pour dire que fait même choix
une dissidence de ses genoux laquelle
tout ça et tout ça pour dire je voudrais
évidemment pas à me remonter jusqu'à
mise de la guerre il ya un port très
important qu était le général boulanger
qui nous devons le droite sort peut-être
que celle à l'ombre portée du général de
gaulle mais non ça commençait avant
c'était déjà le général boulanger
donc c'est très intéressant sur les
attentes de la société française est en
creux des critiques qu'elle porte à
l'institution politique et des vertus
qu'elle prête à la solution militaire
je suis pas sûr pour vous dire éviter
que ça puisse déboucher sur quelque
chose de construire en politique
certains internautes le disent nous ne
voulons plus de politiciens mais devant
d'état je pense que le général de
villiers devrait se faire connaître le
peuple ne le connais sûrement pas
c'est peut-être une solution il utilise
des mots dont personne ne connaît le
sens autre point de vue oui moi je
regarde le sondage d'opinionway cevipof
tous les ans qui parle de la confiance
que les français ont ouvert les vivre en
institution du pays en telle confiance
dans l'armée
donc voilà l'armée arrive en troisième
position avec 77% taux de confiance je
rappelle que les partis politiques eux
n'ont que 13 % de confiance quand
l'armée on à 77% entre parenthèses la
police à 68% de confiance cette année
donc ce qu'ils nous disent tout le monde
déteste la police sont des menteurs les
médias sont à 31% d'envoyer l'armée est
deux fois plus populaire que nous les
médias les journalistes
donc oui il ya une vraie confiance dans
l'armée dans ce pays pour une raison
simple c'est que l'armée comme le
rappelle d'ailleurs de villiers dans son
interview
c'est un creuset de la totalité de la
population toutes les couches sociales
toutes les ethnies toutes les
appartenances politiques religieuses etc
sont dans l'armée sont représentés dans
l'armée qui les brass et en fait quelque
chose de dynamique de souder et c'est
donc face à un par un paysage politique
qui apparaît comme dans l'ensemble des
démocraties comme dans la nôtre clivé
polarisé hystériser parler des bases
parler des réseaux sociaux
vous avez de plus en plus des
extrémistes de plus en plus extrêmes et
d aider des gens qui se haïssent de plus
en plus effectivement l'armée peut
apparaître comme un recours
encore faudrait-il que nous soyons dans
une situation d'une gravité extrême
le recours à l'homme providentiel
deux gradés ça et que ça exige qu'on a
une guerre d'algérie jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on a pas de guerre d'algérie
et puis le général de villiers n'a pas
la légitimité historique
on pourrait imaginer on pourrait
imaginer après tout la droite a pas de
conduire absolument évident ont
prémédité qui joue le jeu il va pas
faire un semis putsch comme le général
de gaulle
il s'agit pas de ça là il pourrait très
bien être le candidat après tout c'est
une des questions en tout cas mais là
enfin on spécule sur en tout cas ce qu
on touche du doigt c'est le besoin de
devant l'autorité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire aux français
pourquoi on se retourne vers un général
et dans la militaire parce que c'est
d'abord de l'autorité et ensuite je
crois une sorte de nostalgie de la
droiture de la grandeur la nostalgie de
l'honneur c'est un excellent moment
de george les vendeurs de châtaignes qui
a vu le prix interallié deux ans la
nostalgie de l'honneur c'est ça aussi
qui travaillent l'opinion française
quand elle joue parce qu'elles jugent
sévèrement ces hommes politiques
après est-ce qu'un militaire avec toutes
ses vertus arrive à s'insérer dans le
jeu politique ou ses vertus sont assez
peu pratiqué et arrive à construire un
parti se faire des fidélités avoir des
daims trouver des fonds c'est une autre
affaire la politique c'est quand même
alors c'est pour ça d'ailleurs il ya un
internautes facétieux qui dit que pense
philippe de villiers de pierre de
villiers il ya parmi les propos
rapportés par ceux qui le fréquentent il
ya beaucoup de propos un conte rapporte
autour du bassin de vie il y en a moi
que je retiens je sais pas s'il le tient
vraiment mais il dit il paraît qu'il
irait si je déclarais quoi que ce soit
tout de suite la droite me tomberait
dessus et serré de me faire chuter c'est
pas c'est plutôt crédible ça
d'abord il dit des choses il sort un
livre et il a une grande page dans le
figaro donc il faut pas qu'ils puissent
ils disaient qu'il est candidat oui mais
surtout si les équipes des candidats
on ne dit pas je suis candidat comme ça
il faut avoir un appareil des
associations des gens qui vous
soutiennent des chefs d'entreprise des
dents dans les départements fin c'est
une machine ça se construit de gaulle
est pas tombée du ciel de gaulle et est
un homme politique redoutable avant
d'être
un militaire il a construit sa machine
de quand il est fait dit quand il reste
ensuite en exil en exil intérêts jusqu'à
58 et travail travail fait venir céder
ses lieutenants il lance des consignes
politiques extrêmement politiciens de
gaulle
c'est pour ça qu'ils gagnent mais le
général honnête vertueux courageux je
crains que dans ce milieu politique qui
n'est pas ça il est peu de chance voilà
c'est ce que vous partagez cette année
oui oui mais je pense pas que je pense
que la situation est pas 6 suffisamment
désespérée pour qu'on recourt à un grade
et vous croyez pas que comme kris kross
qui lie le peuple et conservateurs et
serait derrière lui par contre et
jacques nous dit villiers est à l'heure
ni plus ni moins alors ça par contre
demandé que c'est philippe de villiers
alors on sait pas on aimerait bien avoir
la qualité de la réponse à cette
question effectivement qui était posée
par un autre internaute
le général de villiers doit-il jouer un
rôle en 2022 et bien en tous les cas sur
twitter le général de villiers n'est pas
plébiscité puisque nous vous répondez
non en majorité à 56% et vous étiez 300
à vous exprimer ce qui est sur twitter
plutôt à un chiffre une fourchette haute
il y avait certes un autre attention si
vous et 44% au premier tour c'est
beaucoup c'est 44% dans une logique de
d'élection présidentielle il ya bien des
candidats qui est vrai qu'au dos tandis
que 44 % souhaitent le revoir jouer un
rôle il me semble que le dernier à avoir
fait ça c'était le général de gaulle et
c'était en 1965 mais je la réveille
finale
nous en revenons nous dit anonyme au
fantasme français du général au pouvoir
écouter je vous propose chaque
internaute de voir le dernier
l'interview qui a été accordée donc
alexandre ii v cloud c'est dans le chatt
juste à côté du player et de lire le
livre du général de villiers dont qui
paraît demain l'équilibré et un courage
avec un sous titre réparer la france et
c'est chez fayard demain le figaro
revient alexis sur un modèle mc macron
entre ce qu'on disait entre l'économie
d'un côté la sandale la paix séparatif
sanitaire de l'autre ces deux logiques
qui sont les deux estime d'entre
lesquels il va falloir trouver le juste
point d'équilibré
demain et qui sera peut-être pas celui
de dans huit jours et ni celui dialyse
il ya huit jours donc à retrouver et
avec les premiers articles à retrouver
dès ce soir sur le site du figaro et
rendez vous demain également 11h53 le
tour du monde des idées c'est sur france
culture avec brice couturier merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis nous on se
retrouve un point de vue demain soir à
17 heures avec guillaume roquette
[Musique]